well you have of course great collectors
all over the world and in the United
States of America my greatest admiration
do guys to somebody like mr. Ronald
Lauder who is one of the greatest
collectors I have ever known because
what is unique about him is that his
tastes taste goes from early 20th
century Austrian and German paintings to
contemporary art but equally he buys
medieval works of art she buys old
master paintings drawings and in every
field he has an impeccable eye he has an
amazing sense of quality a totally
unique sense of quality is an artist in
his own right because collecting is a
very creative process but one of the
greatest taste makers and collectors for
the 21st century in late twentieth
century certainly Charles Saatchi at
Phillips de Pury in company we have a
partnership with the Saatchi collection
in London and careers of artists like
Damien Hirst or all the yba is a young
British artists but also the key German
artists the key Chinese artists because
the Saatchi collection is going to
reopen it was a great show t voted to
Chinese art have been very much
happening as a result of the influence
of somebody like Charles Saatchi so he
definitely is one of the great taste
makers and collectors today I have also
great admiration for somebody like
Victor Pinchot in Kiev who's just
created the Pinchuk Art Center and he is
a very bold man who like the great
Russian collectors of the early 20th
century like tsukina Morozov
he buys they shoe Kenan was off were
buying young contemporary artists like
Matisse and Picasso
well Pinchuk has the same approach he
buys the best contemporary artists
worldwide and goes really into it in his
very bold and builds positions for zone
you